una imagen para la historia por primera
vez desde que terminarán los combates en
1953 un líder norcoreano en este caso
kim jong-un un despiadado dictador que
controla con mano de hierro corea del
norte apostó en corea del sur para
declarar su supuesta intención de paz y
desnuclearización ahora bien es este
realmente el momento de la paz que
podemos esperar porque de repente parece
que todo va viento en popa está
dispuesta a corea del norte a renunciar
a la bomba nuclear amigos estas son
algunas de las preguntas que estoy
seguro todos nos estamos haciendo así
que veámoslo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
tarareando paseando o cogiendo se de la
mano brindando y cenando juntos
así es como el pasado viernes 27 de
abril de 2018 pudimos ver a los líderes
de corea del norte y corea del sur
hablamos de la última cumbre
intercoreana en la que los dos países se
comprometieron a buscar un acuerdo de
paz definitivo técnicamente las dos
coreas continúan en guerra a recomponer
sus relaciones y también a perseguir la
desnuclearización de la península
coreana la cumbre tuvo lugar en la zona
desmilitarizada en el poblado de pacman
jones exactamente el mismo lugar donde
se firmó el armisticio de la guerra de
korea
[Música]
tanto el líder norcoreano kim jong-un
como el presidente de corea del sur
muniáin hicieron gala de una aparente
complicidad y amigos hubiera sido muy
pero que muy difícil de imaginar hace
tan solo unos pocos meses
[Música]
y es que lo cierto es que la jornada
dejó imágenes para la historia no estoy
exagerando las escenas que vimos de
paseos apretones de manos y cuchicheos
entre los dos líderes no hubieran
desencajado para nada en el guión de
alguna que otra película romántica
[Música]
e
y sabéis que en cierto modo se trataba
precisamente de eso de un cortejo
político entre dos líderes que no
podrían ser más diferentes
por un lado el presidente de corea del
sur
muniáin un abogado especializado en
derechos humanos un hombre de origen
humilde cuyos padres lograron huir de
corea del norte y que fue durante su
juventud una activista por la democracia
por otro lado kim jong-un uno de los
peores tiranos de todo el planeta
el líder omnipotente de uno de los
países más terribles que podemos
siquiera imaginar
porque amigos a pesar de las imágenes de
la cumbre en las que kim jong-un parecía
casi unos amoroso no olvidemos quienes
realmente no olvidemos que el líder
norcoreano dirige con mano de hierro un
auténtico régimen de terror donde las
violaciones de los derechos humanos son
parte de las funciones rutinarias del
estado hemos casi olvidado las
alegaciones de que habría matado a su
propio hermano con armas químicas justo
el año pasado y que hizo trizas a su tío
con un cañón antiaéreo gary seymour
miembro del consejo de seguridad
nacional del presidente barack obama a
pesar de ello y gracias a las imágenes
que vimos y también a la declaración
acordada por los dos gobiernos la mayor
parte de la prensa no tardó en calificar
este encuentro como una jornada
histórica como el día en que de una vez
por todas triunfó la paz
ahora bien que hay de verdad en todo
esto realmente las cosas van tan bien o
dicho de otro modo estamos ante un
ejercicio sincero o ante una gran
operación de marketing ha cambiado la
hoja de ruta pyongyang el diálogo es
ciertamente mejor que una marcha a la
guerra dicho eso todos debemos mantener
nuestras expectativas bajo control
wendy sherman subsecretaria de estado
para asuntos políticos de 2011 a 2015 y
coordinadora de políticas de corea del
norte en la administración clinton lo
vamos a ver pero antes tenemos que
responder a una pregunta que seguro
muchos nos hemos hecho cómo diantres
hemos pasado en tan sólo unos pocos
meses de escuchar tambores de guerra
peones
es único
lo encuentro tan como decirlo tan
cordial tan armonioso
[Música]
bien
pues nos podemos encontrar tres
explicaciones diferentes pero al mismo
tiempo complementarias al nuevo
comportamiento del régimen de corea del
norte que ha pasado en poco tiempo de
amenazar a los eeuu a suspender sus
pruebas nucleares y de misiles corea del
norte amenaza con convertir a eeuu en un
mar de llamas
corea del norte suspende sus pruebas
nucleares y de misiles
pues bien veamos las posibles causas de
este cambio y ojo ya os adelanto que las
cosas no son tan simples como parecen
atentos
[Música]
pyongyang tenemos un problema
primera explicación posible según varios
analistas de eeuu corea del sur y dos
estudios de investigadores chinos el
centro de pruebas nucleares de punt
diari situado en el corazón de una
montaña de 2200 metros de altura
conocida como la montaña manta podría
haberse derrumbado tras la última prueba
atómica con una bomba termonuclear de
250 kilos tones que corea del norte
detonó en este lugar el pasado 3 de
septiembre de 2017
una explosión tan fuerte que provocó un
terremoto de grado 6 con 3 en la escala
richter pues bien el derrumbe parece un
hecho confirmado lo que no está claro es
si el centro está todavía operativo o no
basándonos en la severidad del estallido
inicial los temblores posteriores a la
prueba y el alcance de las alteraciones
observables en la superficie debemos
suponer que debe de haber habido un daño
sustancial a la red de túneles existente
bajo la montaña manta
frank v fabián y ya que de no ser
operativo o haber quedado muy dañado al
régimen podría llevarle tiempo
reconstruir este lugar para poder
albergar nuevas pruebas de forma segura
lo que en cierto modo podría haber
acelerado los plazos para el anuncio de
suspensión de nuevas pruebas dicho esto
en cualquier caso este sería un factor
que podría haber alterado los plazos
pero no no parece que ésta pueda ser la
causa principal del cambio de discurso
es la economía estúpido
otra hipótesis tiene que ver con el
efecto de las sanciones internacionales
sobre la economía norcoreana como todos
sabéis corea del norte es un país muy
pero que muy pobre pues bien durante
años gran parte de la comunidad
internacional ha impuesto sanciones
sobre corea del norte pero en general
éstas no han afectado a los principales
socios de este país china-rusia vietnam
sin embargo todo esto empezó a cambiar
con las sanciones que en naciones unidas
comenzó a imponer a corea del norte en
2017 como respuesta a las pruebas
nucleares por primera vez estas
sanciones fueron cumplidas en gran
medida por china y eso amigos fue un
duro golpe para este país la inmensa
mayor parte del comercio norcoreano se
produce con china y si eso se corta pues
en pyongyang tienen un problema muy
serio
es un problema amigos que se multiplicó
cuando en septiembre tras la última
prueba nuclear el consejo de seguridad
de las naciones unidas prohibió prohibió
todas las exportaciones clave de corea
del norte incluyendo carbón hierro y
productos textiles de solución
y no sólo eso en diciembre además este
mismo órgano acordó limitar las
importaciones de petróleo refinado a
medio millón de barriles al año una
reducción del 90 por ciento respecto a
las compras de petróleo refinado de
corea del norte el año anterior el
resultado de todo esto pues muchas
fábricas han tenido que cerrar por falta
de materias primas y el ejército ante la
falta de gasolina ha tenido ojo que
recurrirán motores de carbón e incluso a
carros de bueyes tal cual como lo
escucháis
y aunque pueda resultar sorprendente
esta situación no sólo acentúa la
debilidad de corea del norte sino que
además es un duro golpe para el gobierno
de kim jong-un que ha situado como una
prioridad el desarrollo económico y
claro las sanciones ponen en jaque el
nivel de vida de las élites y también de
la incipiente clase media
nuevo incipiente clase media en corea
del norte pues si lo habéis escuchado
bien de hecho os hago una pregunta
creéis que puede estar desarrollándose
un mercado capitalista dentro de la
actual corea del norte pues atento a
nuestros próximos vídeos pero aunque
todo esto es importante y seguro ha
influido tampoco parece algo que pueda
poner en riesgo al régimen no al menos
de momento si usted piensa que los
norcoreanos se revelarán o el régimen se
derrumbará debido a las sanciones usted
no sabe nada acerca de los norcoreanos
estas son personas que sobrevivieron a
la hambruna comiendo malezas
beijing un desertor norcoreano que
trabaja para el banco central de corea
del sur así que amigos entonces por qué
ha cambiado tanto pyongyang su discurso
o es que realmente no ha cambiado nada
atentos
[Música]
objetivo cumplido
corea del norte es una potencia nuclear
esto es un hecho según la inteligencia
norteamericana este país podría disponer
actualmente de entre 20 y 60 ojivas
listas para ser usadas es decir dicho de
otro modo pyongyang ya ha conseguido su
gran objetivo su seguro de vida el mejor
instrumento de visación jamás construido
por el hombre
[Música]
es verdad en la cumbre intercoreana del
pasado viernes 27 de abril lo habréis
escuchado corea del norte prometió
implicarse la desnuclearización de la
península pero un momento porque eso no
implica que este país esté dispuesto a
renunciar a sus armas nucleares primero
porque corea del norte ya ha prometido
muchas cosas que luego ha incumplido las
negociaciones de acuerdos de 1991 del 94
del 2000 del 2007 del 2012 las promesas
norcoreanas no son algo nuevo y hasta
ahora siempre se han quedado en papel
mojado
[Música]
en 1994 el padre de kim jong-hun kim
jong-il llegó incluso a poner en marcha
el desmantelamiento del programa nuclear
y permitió que inspectores
internacionales visitarán el país para
comprobar el proceso todo a cambio de
una generosa ayuda de eeuu sin embargo
años después se supo que todo fue una
farsa el programa continuó su desarrollo
de forma clandestina
en el año 2000 el presidente surcoreano
kim dae jung anunció que un nuevo día
iba a llegar tras volver de visitar a
kim jong-il en corea del norte
en el año 2007 el presidente surcoreano
roh burián afirmó durante su visita a
corea del norte que kim jong-il tenía
una firme intención de restablecer la
paz
y segundo porque no entendemos lo mismo
por desnuclearización veréis para
pyongyang este término tiene mucho que
ver también con las capacidades
militares de eeuu en la península y en
la región y en cualquier caso amigos
parece muy pero que muy difícil que kim
jong-un esté dispuesto a desprenderse de
su mejor seguro de vida kim sigue siendo
en la misma persona que fue cuando purgó
a potenciales rivales encarceló a miles
de su gente y mató a sus parientes este
es un momento de esperanza pero la
extrema precaución está bien justificada
abraham de marc director del programa
asia del centro wilson de hecho y esto
es algo que muestran las comunicaciones
norcoreanas que han sido interceptadas
todo parece formar parte de una especie
de hoja de ruta primero garantizar la
supervivencia del régimen algo que han
conseguido con su arsenal nuclear y
segundo negociar con la comunidad
internacional para poner fin a las
sanciones y poder poner en marcha un
programa de reformas que pueda atraer
inversiones de china y corea del sur
[Música]
es decir lejos de lo que podría
parecernos en un primer momento
pyongyang podría estar siguiendo
simplemente el plan trazado fue la
cumbre intercoreana un gran ejercicio de
marketing esto en cierto modo es lo que
explica el escepticismo con el que la
mayoría de los surcoreanos viven las
promesas del norte atentos a esta
encuesta
[Música]
pero ahora turno para ti crees que corea
del norte renunciará a su programa
nuclear
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta y como
siempre amigos si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte a visual político si
aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
ah